in this lesson we're going to talk about
the very important concept that's tested
on the s80 and that's knowing how to
solve systems of equations so let's go
through a couple examples together and
then we'll have the opportunity to pause
the video so that you can do a couple of
examples on your own and then we'll go
through those together as well so first
of all what's a system of equations well
basically you know it's true equations
ok that represent wine-soaked you
generally and we're looking for where
they cross the point of intersection now
one way to solve these really quickly on
the test is if they give you the points
of intersection you can just go ahead
and plug in those points so for example
if one of the possibilities the multiple
choice answers was like negative 12 you
could say well i'm going to put negative
1 in for X I'm going to put two in for y
if that makes that equation true and if
I put it negative 1 in for X here and 2
and 4 y and that makes the second
equation true but makes both the
equations true we know that's the common
point of intersection and that's our
answer so you can back substitute that
can be a very quick and efficient way to
do these types of problems but sometimes
that's not an option so let me show you
another way to solve these problems so
the first way we're going to talk about
it's the substitution method so here
what you have is since y equals 2x plus
1 let's go ahead and substitute or put
that in place of y in the second
equation this way we'll get everything
in terms of just one variable X so let's
go ahead and do that so we've got three
X minus 2 instead of why I'm putting
what y equals which is 2x plus 1 equals
negative 6 now i'm going to distribute
the negative 2 so that gives us 3x minus
4x minus 2 equals negative 6 combine
like terms that's negative 6 minus 2
equals negative 6 add 2 to both sides
multiply by negative 1 or divide by
negative 1 and you can see that x equals
4 now if we want to find out what Y is
we can take X put it back into this
equation or this equation either one
you'll get the same answer I'm going to
go ahead and put it back in for X right
here so that's going to be 2 times 4 is
8 plus 1 is 9 so our answer is going to
be 4 comma 9 now again if this was given
as one of the solutions you could go
ahead and back substitute to see if it
makes both equations true and you can
verify
that is the correct answer so that's
called the substitution method the other
method is called the elimination method
and what you do here is you try to add
the equations together in such a manner
that either the x's cancel out or the
y's cancel out right so for this one
what i'm going to do is on the multiply
it everything is second equation by
negative 2 so that this will be negative
2x when i add it to positive 2x the exes
are going to cancel one another out okay
so you're with me so far so let's go
ahead and multiply everything here by
negative 2 that gives us negative 2x
minus 2y equals negative 14 I'm just
going to bring that top equation down
below it okay like so and if we go ahead
and add these together now you can see
the exes are canceling one another out
and we get negative 5y equals negative
25 divide everything by negative 5 and
you can see that y equals 5 now all we
have to do is take that five put it back
in for Y into either one of these
equations I'm going to put it here
because it can be a little bit easier
and we've got X plus 5 equals 7 subtract
5 from both sides and you can see that x
equals 2 so our final answer is going to
be the cop the coordinate to count of
five now sometimes then the s80 it will
say you know solve for x + y and in
which case you would just add these
together you would say two plus five at
seven and that's your answer or it'll
just say what's the the y coordinate you
would just let you know the Y value you
don't have to list bulk points so pay
attention to the format they give it to
you in but basically you can use a
substitution elimination or the back
substitution method to solve these
systems of equations so now here's your
turn to get some practice let's do these
two problems here go ahead and pause the
video to see if you can stall them on
your own will go through them together
the first one it says what is the value
of B such that the system has no
solution okay so when you look at these
two equations here you know what does
this devalue have to be so that there's
no solution so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do it on your own
we'll go through it together okay so
let's take a look so we talked about the
elimination here in this example let's
take a look at elimination for this one
as well what would we have to do to
let's just say eliminate the Y values
here well what we could do is we can
multiply the second equation by negative
2
would give us negative 10x minus 6y
equals negative 24 right so now when we
add these together the first and third
like this we're going to get D minus 10x
the 6 line negative 6 larger to cancel
and we get 8 plus negative 24 which is
negative 16 now in order for there to be
no solution we want not just the
y-values to cancel out but also the X
variables to cancel out as well so if d
ok was this is actually supposed to be
DX here but if d was 10 you're going to
get 10x minus 10x equals negative 16
which is 0 equals negative 16 which
doesn't make any sense it's a
nonsensical answer and what that means
is that these two lines are parallel and
that they don't intersect they don't
cross okay so that's the idea here now
another way to approach this problem is
you could rewrite the equation in y
equals MX plus B form that's the slope
intercept form and as long as the two
equations have the same slope but
different y-intercepts what that
represents is they're going up at the
same angle okay but they're crossing the
y-axis at a different point those two
lines also will not have a common point
of intersection because they're parallel
so a couple different ways one way is to
use the elimination method and if both
the variables cancel out such that you
get two quantities that don't equal one
another then there's no solution now if
you would have gotten zero equals zero
or negative 16 equals negative 16 then
what that means is that they're the
exact same line okay one line is right
on top of the other line and they're
actually crossing at an infinite number
of points okay let's look at example
number to see if you can pause the video
do this lie on your own will go through
together it says if your friend has
already read 150 pages and reads 20
pages an hour and you have just started
the book and you read 30 pages an hour
how long will it take you to catch up to
your friend okay so see if you can solve
this system of equations to find out how
long it's going to take for you to catch
up to your friend in this particular
book that you're both reading okay so
first thing I want to do is we want to
write the equation so
to say that your friend ok is reading 20
pages and I on let's see 20 pages in our
rights or 20 times the number of hours
plus they've already read 150 pages and
that's going to be the total number of
pages that they've read now notice that
this equation is very similar to the y
equals MX plus B form of a line the M is
the slope or the rate ok and the D is
the y-intercept or the initial condition
of starting about how many pages he's
already read or she's already read right
now the second equation is relating to
how many pages that you read you read 30
pages per hour so if it's two hours you
will have read 60 pages three hours 90
pages but your initial condition your B
value is 0 because you haven't started
the book yet right ok so this is our
system right here we want to solve the
system I think the easiest way to do
this is just to do this substitution
method so P equals 30 H let's go ahead
and put 30 inch in place of P so that's
30 H equals 20 h plus 150 subtract 28
from both sides right can you want to
get the variables on one side numbers on
the other divide everything by 10 to
solve for 1 h and you can see it's going
to be 15 hours so in 15 hours maybe not
all in the same day but after 15 hours
of reading you're going to catch up to
where your friend is at in the book so
this is a very important concept
understanding systems of equations on
the SA TEF emphasize it quite a bit in
many different forms where you might
have to write the equations yourself and
solve the system they may give you the
equations and you have to solve the
system you might have to find a value
where there's an infinite number of
solutions or no solution or you know it
might just be like a you know some kind
of variation of what we talked about
here so review the lesson if you need to
i'll see you in the next lesson